thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
us
ES
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
eyes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign guys
[Music]
all right all right here we go
let me move this back a little bit
in case my girlfriend
[Music]
chilling in her car
[Music]
let me call her real quick guys before
we start this this journey
[Music]
hey have you left yet
have you left yet
okay I just you've pulled out now though
right
okay well I saw those people out back
and I didn't want to start streaming
until I saw you out
all right
all right
can you guys see this fine let me let me
make this a little bit smaller
so as you can see I have put 45 minutes
into the game I like to do the tutorial
on my own so I can learn how to play the
game so you guys don't see me how to
play the game
I played a good amount of the first one
I didn't beat it though
[Music]
because I just didn't like the first one
[Music]
so so far the the gameplay I will say is
better
then the gameplay I saw in the original
one
I will be reviewing this after I beat
the game
man I haven't had cold right in forever
I'm on this new thing like
I'm cutting back on soda because I've
been addicted to soda like my whole life
so now I'm only drinking like one a day
until I can uh into the the sugar
withdrawals is is tangible where I
cannot drink it at all
I don't like how there's no run button
to my knowledge like there's no run
button I'm not really feeling that
what's good what's in the door
light inside the temple to unlock this
door
what Temple
I didn't see a temple
I assume that's the temple over there
you know I'm sure you guys could tell me
if I'm wrong or right
man I forgot Luigi got messed up is that
the temple
look at this big dude over here
how would you like to fight someone like
him
let me switch to this
I assume this is the temple
how do I we gotta figure out how to
oh
[Music]
what's going on
that's a big dude to be scared of such a
little creature
I assume that's gonna be the first boss
what is this
Temple interest flies it's like a
teleportation system
apparently Augie believes he's from the
family of proud demigods for such Divine
creatures
unfortunately legal depiction of the
birth of all right
so far this looks like a ball like a
room that you fight oh there's that that
creature what they're called Sparks I
think I think they're called Sparks
there
all right there we go
perhaps we could cross over it without
blank but we'd need to raise
so a little bit of looks like some
puzzle features in this guy
a little bit of puzzles
what's going on okay there we go
okay
is this do I have to get the water oh I
have to free up the water okay
pretty simple puzzle
just push this back
and this back
pretty simple puzzle
all right hold up
hold up
it's not simple anymore guys
all right
all right so
hold up maybe you have to get rid of one
yep
there we go
see that's how you do it guys
foreign
[Applause]
wasn't really complicated
I like
I do like the new way that they're
establishing battles in here the other
one's like kind of like a like multiple
chess boards on one like little map you
go to one to the other and that's how
you did this this does seem like it's
telling a story better than that did
all right so I can't do him
but I can do a team jump
and come over here
all right so we can get them
that's fine though
we're gonna take this dude
yeah he just hit him as much as you can
probably could have left him alive I
don't think it would have mattered to be
honest
to be honest with you
Mario's about to get lit the hell up
though oh my God
yo these things don't play
yeah
Luigi's just about tooken out
got a little bit of a health thing
let's flank this dude
what's up bud
these Goombas are kind of crazy
so you could take one of them out but
you're not gonna be able to take all of
them out
and you can only do that once
let's go
all right
Turbo Charge now we don't want to do
that what we're doing is just gonna hit
him man we can take two of them just
take two of them out okie dokie
all right let's listen listen let's get
cumbered up they're gonna hit us pretty
hard especially Luigi
dead
regardless they took out Luigi we could
still do this guys
oh yeah
easy Luigi was a sacrifice for lamb but
we did it we did it easy
30 coins
yum
gotta love those coins
I want some like actually complicated
fights I like how they don't let you
keep like your health doesn't re respond
afterwards
because I've always I could I don't like
when games like just give you health
back after a battle like those those
kind of get on my nerves
I feel like you you should have to use
resources to get your health back in any
game it doesn't matter what it is
what is this
oh this is just the store dude I like
how they actually put a store in the
game and not just like some random
upgrade screen that was in the first one
that's interesting
probably gonna be a boss
man if only this game was on like
consoles that actually can make it run
properly but you could tell there's some
frame rate drops I mean it's a
turn-based game so it's not really like
a huge issue but you could tell that the
game should be running better
I love how you only have two people but
you're running around for like five
where's the other four when you're doing
stuff that's another criticism I give
these this this franchise they don't
really let you use too many characters
not a variety of gameplay but I'm only
using two people
it's not like a bad thing I don't think
like I take points from it uh because I
do think the game is designed for two
people but I think it could be better if
there was more
indeed without the spark we will not be
able to enter the like
that is fun from the only reason
obviously defeating the darkness
tentacles oh like there's like a little
higher density of Darkness a little
banter between the two
one's good and one's bad yin yang kind
of thing about
oh
oh I already went this way
so I guess we're gonna fight this thing
we're gonna win too chat
like don't let these things think we
can't win level three that could be a
level 10 man I don't need none of that
nonsense
I'm built to win
so there's the new spark up there we got
to get to it
I'm definitely going to take this to the
girlfriend's house after the Stream
super effects can be applied to
potentially anyone generally you know uh
unique Behavior here the burn super
effect sets its Target
a light I would prefer that actually
shows you what it looks like in battle I
don't like when games give you tutorials
but they don't show you it in the actual
game
super effects are weak against enemies
if you take care to avoid their
resistance and exploit the weaknesses
for example the scooper is weak against
a burn all right so there's like a
damaging effect kind of thing going on
in this game
equip one of your Heroes is a pricer
might then be a good strategic move
anyways remember to use the technician
by pressing the weakness okay
so let's do this
I ain't scared
I ain't scared
I don't know what this is though so
we're gonna use it I'm assuming it's to
get us closer yeah
but then ads are going to show up the
moment I go closer
oh
oh okay
let's set up right here
no we're gonna kill him
[Music]
I wonder if you get hold up hold up hold
up
let's give the spark to uh to Luigi to
make him stronger
did the team jump try to get behind the
enemy
it doesn't do as much damage as I would
I would have liked
[Music]
all right so let's hit him
it's pretty decent there
I do like how he ran
but now I'm in
I'm very exposed 100 shots
it's getting hit again no okay
let's go and kill that dude he's got a
50 chance of not getting shot but I
think we can get him there we go
doesn't take too much
let's move Mario up here
zero percent chances of shooting
I wish there was an OverWatch in this
game I feel like the game would run
functionally a lot better if there's an
OverWatch
but there isn't so what we're going to
do is uh
we're gonna aims for this dude by
blowing up some of that cover
and then we're just going to enter
foreign
[Music]
full cover right now so we got really
not too much to worry about
there's there's three enemies though
that's a lot of damage
I think what I want to do is I want to
destroy that cover
since Mario can shoot twice I'm gonna
shoot both of them
okay
but now I can use Luigi to do a team
jump
let's get right here
so comfortable here
no I don't feel comfortable let's get
right here
no
all right
yeah all right so we good right there
what's up Erica
trying the streaming thing man you know
I'm trying the streaming thing
all right let's keep Luigi where he is
because I want Mario to be able to team
jump off of him
we pull up on people here
just like that
just like that how does the stream look
Erica
like the other people can tell me
but the question is is I got to see how
like another content creator feels about
the stream because I feel like you would
have a little bit more input than than
most other people are because you stream
as well
oh yeah oh yeah
pretty easy shot may I say so myself
I like the game so far
but I gotta see out evolves the reason I
like the last one that's because I felt
like it didn't evolve
and they are shooting Mario like crazy
you know what let's team jump over here
to this cover
[Music]
there's black bars around it there's
black bars around the actual game that's
the funny part like that's not like me
messing up that's literally the game
hold up
I'm at the Finesse it if I want to fix
it
[Music]
that's crazy that I have to literally
stretch it a little bit because in the
actual game
all right how is that
it's still a little bit
no it's not intentional it's just how
the game was
it's still not what it should be
it's a little bit better I'll probably
fix that before I stream again I don't
know if I'll stream this game again but
I'll have to fix it
and that's it
Luigi you failing me man
you had that shot I don't know what
happened there
Mario is just getting lit up
they'll let these snipers just shoot
like crazy
all right
I can't reach him
I can reach him but I don't know if I
want to do that
he's got zero percent child
I can't even reach the other dude I
gotta use Luigi
all right so Luigi got some moves I'll
give him that he's got some moves
what are you
oh
oh lost health for out of bounds
okay
all right
there we go
oh we hit him both times
now we've already did but Luigi is in
half cover I guess now both of them are
in half cover this isn't looking good
for me man they're doing a lot of damage
to me
We're Not Gonna We're Not Gonna
be scared yet though
[Music]
wow those things got a lot of Health
yeah
yeah all right
all right so I didn't get that dude at
all
I just wish it ran better Erica because
it it it it is a little
a little suspect
Luigi's getting lit up
I don't want to go there because then
he's completely open up for attack there
no yeah
it's good let's get rid of that cover
half cover is good
50 chance of shot
missed
that's unfortunate
all right so clearly he can hit him from
there
come on hit him thank you
[Music]
oh can I make it over there can I make
it over there
no I can't
oh
[Music]
I should have I probably should have
killed him first
oh
put him like right here
I'm thinking that
he won't be available to shoot behind
him yeah see it worked out
I think I'm good if I as long as I get
to that area I think I'm good
let's do a team jump and just go
straight for the green
yep
but I'm pretty hurt so I'm kind of
nervous by that I'm pretty hurt
got this little cute spark how far are
you Erica
I'm totally gonna eat on stream by the
way guys I'm hungry
I don't understand why they're they're
here but they're not in the combat like
it's so frustrating like it's got such a
unique type of like x-com gameplay and I
feel like it would be so much better if
I could use more people
what is that
[Music]
okay thank you
oh
who is this
[Music]
I wish they'd use dialogue more man
it's like a cloud wannabe is that what
we got going here
he's fast though
I hope I can use this dude and I hope
he's not like one of those people where
he's a uh
just a character like that that stalks
you and you never can use them
[Music]
what is he doing
[Music]
oh this is a boss
oh God
[Music]
what's that tiger from the cereal that's
what that thing looks like that tiger
from that cereal
defeat the giant wild claw it's probably
going to be a regular enemy here in a
minute
once we actually do this
having three here was cooperating on the
battlefield would give a huge Advantage
oh so three Heroes now okay
hello
the iPhone 13.
then try the pro then try the pro it
might be the pro I don't know
I I don't know
like look look in the info of the phone
I'm sure it'll tell you
well I don't know like I don't know
nothing about iPhone stuff babe
let's finish this
well ask ask an associate
I gotta go though
all right
[Music]
my chat's not big enough to to dictate
my stuff yet they they don't talk a
whole lot
[Music]
look at this tiger
I want whatever the standard difficulty
is
so it looks like he's got a spark
is he fast
no it's a flying blade so he'll throw it
storm blade
all ties within range are dealt okay
all right
let's do a little bit of damage real
quick
got the sniper
yeah take care of that one
let's get rid of that
[Music]
oh I like this dude
This Cloud wannabe is what's up
all right I think I've already went I
don't think I can go anymore
wait oh
Luigi's a little safe there I don't
support that dude that's not good for
him those appear to be talking
enjoy them quick
all right so we gotta destroy a Darkness
portal I think our best bet to destroy
that would be Luigi because he's a
sniper
can we get closer
once if I get right here
yeah there we go
I'd rather take a little bit of damage
and not have to deal with an enemy
coming out of that portal
yeah the music
[Music]
whoa
oh that's nice
we hit them
oh he he ain't he ain't happy
oh my God that thing we don't want to
get hit by that again
all right he's not gonna do what he did
last time
[Music]
120 of damage the dude's got 901 left so
that wouldn't really help
all right putting on that OverWatch
and we're gonna shoot him twice
because that's how we do things and the
Mario's gonna get lit the hell up
my bad Mario
oh
hit Luigi hit Luigi thank you
[Music]
oh Mario you got this don't die oh
it's not looking good there's two of
them now
[Music]
I'm moving back
hold up
I'm streaming
all right so I gotta have a little bit
of room between me and them
all right hold up hold up
I don't know what you that what I just
did
that's not the fire one
we shooting them
oh he's shot twice that's what I do
foreign
[Music]
not too bad
[Music]
that's how you successfully
defeat something we sacrificed Mario for
the greater good of mankind
and I wouldn't I wouldn't do it any
other way Mario had to go that was the
only way to make that successful
oh
excuse me intimidating stranger it's
vitally important that the spell comes
until we destroy the lighthouse tentacle
we can't create War Turtles to other
planets look how unappealing that Dude
Looks he looks so upset
look how happy the spark looks though
dude's weird
oh he's a spark Hunter oh his name's
Edge
good rabbit Edge welcome to
oh it's a rabbit spaceship huh
I believe it's time we start keeping
three Heroes on our front line
oh clearly the three that's on the
actual thing
giant enemies
oh
[Music]
I wonder what that is
oh it's that it's that Throne teleporter
what is this
[Music]
I don't know what to do here
is there
something showing it
all right this one
do you put them facing each other
nope I'm not really that interested in
finding out
what is that oh it's Koopa
thank you
done
these fights don't really take too much
it looks like
the loading screens is kind of
ridiculous
the switch really needs another
iteration what 17s when the switch came
out
four years
I know that's not a long time but I
don't feel like you can compare the
switch to like normal standards either
we're going for that Koopa
oh I was so close
okay hold up
I'm gonna use the sniper
I don't know why that's not killing us
there we go
there we go
it's a nice little move man I like him
this dude goes hard
anyone else simple
foreign
what is this
that'll work
while clothes I don't know what I just
grabbed
welcome
okay
was that a shortcut to the beginning
maybe you know I think that's the way
that we came from
what is this
take a note off
all right let's go then
I'm sure in case you hate walking as
much as I do
yeah so I'll go this way
sometimes they don't make no sense man
yeah rogo the the music's pretty good
starting not to feel they keep using the
same stages over and over again though
more
uh I bet you we can hit this dude
[Music]
okay so we don't need that
we do need
is to hit each one of those
how'd you guys like that
that was big move moments right there
it's ridiculous that they can reach me
that far
foreign
get these level UPS
gotta gotta get that Health up though
hmm yeah
I wonder what those are
he said there's a quicker way
he's not being very vocal
I can't imagine what it could cause oh
get it
take a note off
okay you clearly you're not gonna listen
so I'm just gonna go this way
do I go straight
I don't know
I wish you could run it's so annoying
that you can't run
okay there's that dude then who's this
dude over here
what's this dude
if only yeah
oh he's probably tell me how to solve
that over there
all right I don't really care
will you help me revise it before it's
forgotten completely I'm convinced it is
somewhere in the room the answer to the
riddle of the Temple of Beacon Beach
magically translate card at the Chamber
of the two suns you understand when you
hear the riddle the King Pins the star
on the favorite Sun
the outcast runs away towards a new dawn
the painting is a temple of the haunt uh
of The Haunting beautiful I suspect
they're connected to the Roto somehow
is it true to anything from it could be
solved okay let's see this
his whole life Augie was eclipsed by his
old twitch before honest do I really
care about this enough probably not
let's just go
I like the the the battle system in the
game
more than anything to be honest with you
guys
I guess this is the shortcut the dude
was talking about
this doesn't seem like a shortcut to me
thank you
this probably goes back outside
one would think this would go back
outside
once again taking too long to load
I hope this is like a boss boss like
someone Worthy
of my time
[Music]
until we meet again bye bye
so just took off you could help
I think we're gonna fight a boss at the
top of this this is probably like the
boss for the world
[Music]
oh
I see
I ain't scared of you
oh my God the loading screens man
how did we go from like that little room
to out here in the middle of the see
that's one of the biggest thing I just
don't agree with for the most part I
told you into fighting those those big
creatures
so if you win the battle I will join
your Heroes and leave here forever
watch The Flaming scores they burn
effects can light multiple uh Heroes on
fire if they're too close together
forcing you to scatter if you come into
contact with anyone else on fire they'll
catch you on fire too tough luck but
that's luck for you
let's finish this all right
let's put him over here
I kind of want Luigi to actually snipe
someone
it's a shame I couldn't get in actual
[Music]
no we want this one
we want this
let's shoot the dude not in any what's
any cover whatsoever look at this tiger
what is that Tony the Tiger I think
that's what his name is
hmm
oh yeah
yeah move towards me
you know what
hero site because when I shoot him he's
gonna walk towards me
so we're going to use this wannabe Cloud
a little hit him with this sword and
then he's gonna come at me because I hit
him and he's gonna get [ __ ] shot by
Mario
and that my friends is how you kill Tony
the Tiger
thank you
now let's just let them do what it is
[Music]
similar to Kingdom Hearts but I wouldn't
say it sounds like Kingdom Hearts of
Mexicans over
take care of him
I'm not really feeling that
hold up all right
[Music]
so it's probably what not the greatest
idea for me to put him out in uh no
cover
Mario's about to get lit up
I'll make you move
and he moves quite a bit oh
well it looks like there's only three
okay we took care of him
Let's get someone up there at the top
actually
I want to get Luigi up there at the top
because he's uh he's a sniper I feel
like he would be
better off up there
come on go go
is this there we go
bam
clean shot
we good
he's gonna shoot Luigi okay try to shoot
Mario but he didn't get it
try to shoot Luigi he didn't get it
his father
we will finish him off
it's a shame that he can't reach him
because he is pretty powerful
just in case five minutes
all right there we go
pretty simple
Tony the Tiger ain't very effective if
uh it's so easy to to damage clock his
ass
[Music]
did it
Moving on Up Moving On Up to the next
flow
what is this
it's going to come back yep
oh yeah I bet you I'll push this
[Music]
their puzzles don't really try to be
puzzles do they
try to be pretty simple
I have no clue what this is
pretty simple
Ubisoft connect level up units earned
so clearly I'm doing something right
it's like for this dude go over
get him
oh
man this fakes forever
is another Tony the Tiger
the Tony the Tiger's not going to be too
hard because he's so far away
but I feel like I got to take out the
bomb first real quick
let's just throw him out oh
[Music]
that's fine pathetic
hold up
I need
Mario to get closer
so first off let's do this here it'll
fight
let's get them again Chad
then move him over
let's just shoot him once yeah
yeah
see
he's not too complicated man
see then I can shoot regular
but I'm not going to be able to hit him
I don't want to get him closer to me
all right I got as far as a wave as I
could
yes he's got like no movement speed
whatsoever
[Music]
he probably moves faster when you
actually shoot him like that than he
does
right
he's not too hard to take out
I should have probably thought about his
character a little bit more I felt like
they didn't
that's their loss though it's not mine
coins
we can always use more coins
I haven't really bought anything in this
game yet
I normally when it comes to these type
of things I don't buy anything until I'm
struggling a little bit where I feel
like I need to upgrade stuff
what is this
probably like one of those things is in
there
what happened
what is this yeah right here
now I gotta move it down
on this little platform that I can go up
give you guys a little
little first level action on a Mario
oh I think this is the boss of the level
okay
is there not a way to
to look at
your team well you probably have to do
that team management thing
I think this is the actual
last boss of this place
well he's huge is that him in the middle
yeah
he's got a lot of ads around him this is
going to be pretty
pretty solid fight guys
we're going to Prevail the
what is that
toxic quake
I feel like the spark storylines could
have been done better
all right let's see here
so you can change the difficulty I don't
think I'm gonna do that yet Erica
I'm not against it though just not right
now
we don't really need none of that
[Music]
all right let's start
we got to kill all of these things
the good thing with Mario is we can kill
two of them
how about we get rid of him
that'd be helpful
they're not very vocal about people you
have to kill are they
'd be easy to miss them if you don't pay
attention
yeah he's gonna shoot some people
it's cool we're fine not too bad not yet
oh he's doing a good amount of damage
though
all right hold up
shooter
foreign
[Music]
the good thing is Mario because probably
can hit them both
we don't want those yet
we want to kill the the enemies that's
gonna hurt us or you can miss the only
real shot that you had
perfectly an option too
foreign
so they did a little bit of damage to
Mario
all right let's get rid of
we're gonna have him hit him
and we're gonna take the bomb
and kill him
and then shoot two of these
foreign
it's fine though
yeah
yeah make sure Luigi can kill them with
one shot
oh he can't
[Music]
hold up yeah
[Music]
yeah I've already shot with him so I
can't do that
I'll talk with him
all right let's make sure we killed this
thing
the last thing we need is this thing
being able to come back and shoot
that'd be that'd be horrible we don't
want that
what we want is we want to kill this
thing
[Music]
sure we might be a little bit exposed
here just a little bit probably take a
little bit more damage but there's no
ads coming back up to shoot us
foreign
[Music]
let's do this one we want that
guaranteed shot Mario can't take another
hit
there we go
all right so we're good right there
unfortunately we can't reach that on
time
it doesn't look like there's too many of
these left though
[Music]
okay Mario you got to move a little bit
so you can do a team jump on you
oh there's a bunch of eyes over there
I'm not really worried about the eyes
right now
that was a zero percent chance of
hitting that I kind of wasted
wasting a bunch of stuff and I put him
straight out in the middle of nowhere
he's probably gonna get shot
[Music]
you're gonna break that yep half damage
oh that'll keep bringing them out I
gotta kill that thing fast
I don't know
all right so they do disappear
and then they blow up on me
get rid of this thing
that's that that will
Luigi's hurt
foreign
[Music]
oh my God please hit him that would have
been nice to have a critical but it's
not the end of the world
I gotta get him in in this battle
wait
whoa
yeah
oh yeah
haha
hey
I hear you gotta finish that first one
I I just didn't I don't know why I just
didn't like it nothing against the game
it's just I guess it just wasn't for me
okay can I not hit him there
man they got me in such a weird position
wait go on oh they let him shoot the
moment he comes out actually that
actually worked out good for me I needed
him closer to me
I wish I had something to bring
Mario back to life
[Music]
all right so I don't think you can bring
him back to life like that
okay
50 chance I gotta get him
thank you
watch her baby I don't want her phone
all right
all right everyone man let's hope that
they don't kill my uh Luigi they kill
Luigi it's it's a rat
oh
please don't be able to shoot good okay
so far so good
there we go just dead weight
[Music]
[Music]
okay we got this sniper situation going
of course he's gonna miss
I'm gonna grab these bombs
oh
go on
I only got one more mushroom
s
hits the spot
off you go
[Music]
so I did do a good reminder
[Music]
there's no reason you can't shoot one of
those
[Music]
[Music]
that's not gonna kill
him but he'll kill that dude
I don't know if I'd go back to it to be
honest with you
oh he missed thank you that half is
helping
foreign
there we go
things are starting to go better now
because I have access to more cover
I can't
I'm going down there and laying this
dude up
got to get this storm blade going on
chat
laughs
all right
I can't shoot him
to try to get rid of him
and it blew up in my face
hmm
full cover Man full cover
age
oh
yeah
no he hits them both we're good
want more
let's see here
Oh I thought it would let me redo it
automatically
[Music]
one of these things or I can destroy the
own cover I have
it's always good shoot the only cover I
have
bird attack
yeah oh he's resistant to it
yeah I'm kind of stupid I should have
known the better yeah
[Music]
we're gonna we'll mess him up
we're gonna storm blade and we're gonna
hit him
[Music]
foreign
but then Luigi's gonna be able to flank
him
I'm gonna spawn anyone
that'd be unfortunate
they probably will
[Music]
they shouldn't I killed everyone here on
my own they shouldn't spot anyone
I can't hit that one over there so we're
gonna get out of coverage
all right we should be good now
foreign
[Music]
oh
that fight was a little intense
[Music]
[Music]
and we did it
first world done
watch him be the the actual last box
oh boy
I like how everyone knows what sparks
are now
oh so there's three Sparks left in this
area they will answer to all of us for
although we have enough purified
Darkness energy to travel to pristine
Peaks those warp tunnels go both ways
you're my I just don't like the the no
dialogue man
all right so I guess this is telling me
like
thank you
there's a spark here
there's a spark here
they said that was three
all right you guys I'm gonna go ahead
and call it a stream yeah hang out with
the girlfriend spend a little time with
her
all right look
I'll have to give you guys my opinion
when I've reviewed the game uh I'm still
about 50 50 right now 50 50. that's all
you getting right now but I'll talk to
you